people of the internet retro reckons who
are here and welcome back to harry
potter and the chamber of secrets
gryffindor
vs hufflepuff coming right up quidditch
match
next if you are checking out the channel
for the first time you should know i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they till
what is wrong with his face dude
what is this like some weird reflection
why is he blue with like demonic red
eyes
oliver wood my friend what's happened to
you
i was just trying to do my intro guys
just just trying to do my intro
dude you know what he looks like he
looks like
oh what's her name from uh charlie in
the chocolate factory
violet beauregard that is what he looks
like
as i was saying though in my intro there
guys i'm just a dad who loves games and
the stories
they tell we post videos every week
right here
on youtube and we've got a full let's
play up of harry potter and the
philosopher's stone on the pc
and now we're making our way through
harry potter and the chamber of secrets
here on the nintendo gamecube
let's go ahead and go into the quidditch
stadium and get this match going
yeah here we go
[Applause]
it's been a while since we did the the
quidditch thing i got to make sure i
remember
how to do this okay a to go
and then we just have to oh goodness
they knocked me off my path right
there
[Applause]
you guys know at some point we're gonna
have to play quidditch world cup
we're gonna have to i said i said i was
gonna replay the harry potter games
hey harry potter and the quidditch world
cup that's that's part of it man
[Applause]
i gotta decide when that one will fall
though
because they're probably gonna do
prisoner of azkaban after we finish this
yeah get that boost right there oh no
oh no gryffindor scored i've lost all my
rings
whoa oh man we've lost all the rings
because we went too fast see
i shouldn't have used the uh the boost
because i think it messed me up
what's this way behind come on i'm not
way behind i've got another boost ready
but
i don't know if i should use it right
now wait so i get on like a little
straight away
[Applause]
wait for it wait for it
there we go come on come on potter
[Applause]
there we go gryffindor takes it home
190 to 10.
take that hufflepuff take that sorry to
my hufflepuff folks out there
sorry but you know we had that we had to
just in that one as quickly as possible
uh wait what oh i thought
you know how most uh scoreboards and
things like that you have like the win
loss tie
i thought it i thought it was saying
that we had one one
lost zero and then tied i'm i'm kind of
confused though wait
so what is the p
what is the what is the p played because
we've already played
did we not play a quidditch match
already
i thought i remembered a seven quid in
quidditch match maybe i'm thinking back
to
the first uh harry potter and the
philosopher's stone
yeah i guess not i guess we only played
one quidditch match here so
there you go gryffindor wins looks like
slytherin also defeated
ravenclaw 300 to 60.
so let's move on here and see what
happens next well played harry
i suppose you're worn out after that
well i think you're right i'm going to
bed
going to bed wait is this end of day
let's see how many beans i have wait is
that a chest right there
oh oh but it requires incendio
and we do not have incendio yet we do
have pretty much
everything else though see that's the
only spell we're missing so
anything requiring scourge we defendo we
we've got that
so there's only one spell that we lack
so i'm gonna go
when i get back up here to the castle
i'm just gonna look around for a little
bit
before we go up and in the day
anyway yeah what up malfoy
anything interesting happened last night
nope not at all dude
not at all not a thing interesting
happened you know what i also need to
check and see where the next like hidden
item is
the the little items that you have to
find for the students
oh man all these doors are locked come
on we just want to go explore
oh wait the great hall is open the
door's locked oh what
then why doesn't it stay locked
all right let's try this side
[Music]
oh locked again it doesn't say
locked though for whatever reason i
don't know
looks like you can't go in any of these
areas right now
oh here we go another incendio guys we
gotta remember when we finally unlock
incendio there are going to be a lot of
places can't get through there
yeah that i i don't think they want us
getting in there
guys i think that one is locked down
tight
all right let's go and head left over
here
i feel like there was at least one more
chest around here that had scourge
all the students just instantly turned
to look at harry
oh yes that's an alomora chest perfect
perfect
and this is the the little area where
you could use the game boy advance link
man i remember setting that up i cannot
remember
what it did i had the gba i had the link
cable
okay we gotta face this way harry
was your card maybe yes
nicely done all right it looks like we
need two more to increase
our health tail myron wagtail
1972 the present lead singer of popular
wizarding band
the weird sisters very nice very nice
all right so yeah we need two more to
increase our health there
finding lots and lots of user cards all
right well it was worth a little detour
to go over there
now i'm gonna do the same thing when we
go this way
because we already checked everywhere
down there i think we're good
so this is still in the daytime so we're
probably gonna have a night mission
coming up
but yeah i hope all you guys out there
watching are doing well
e3 and the summer games fest just
wrapped up unfortunately we did not get
any hogwarts legacy news
i know i'm as sad as you guys but
hopefully soon hopefully soon there's
still a couple events before the year
ends
maybe we will see it before 2022 in some
capacity
but yeah my life is uh kind of calming
down a little bit right now my wife and
i are getting ready to take a little uh
kind of a long weekend vacation my mom's
gonna watch the kids
we have not went anywhere since covid
started
my wife and i in terms of like just us
you know
oh is this another one wait what is that
one looks like i've already opened that
i think that's defindo
yeah so it'll be nice just to get away
for a couple days
now that everything's starting to open
back up
and then my my son his baseball season
is done
they went 17-0 guys 17-0
won their last game the championship by
one run it was
crazy it was crazy they were actually
down they were down four runs
going into the bottom half of the final
inning
so they had to get four runs to tie it
and
five runs to win and they did it man
it was intense i saw the perfect season
just
flashing before my eyes but they found a
way to get it done
all right so this is the transfiguration
room i'm not gonna sit here and go
through every single one of these i was
just double checking to make sure there
wasn't a chest
somewhere that we had missed or hadn't
unlocked already
honestly the one thing i do want to
check i need to see how many birdy bop
beans i have only
13. see that's unfortunate because once
nightfall hits
that is the point when you can buy stuff
from fred and george so
i should probably try and get a little
bit more
seriously nothing in that one come on
man
oh my goodness another chest recording
in city oh but here we go we got one
that requires scourge
let's go ahead and uh put that back on
right there
use that lock on feature
i see the problem is we're gonna have to
do this again once we get incendio
because there's so many that require
incendio
all right one more wizard card needed
roland keg
roland keg 1903 to present president of
the
english gobstones team dude i forgot all
about
gobstones it's been a while since i've
reread the books i need to reread them
but yeah
like until i read that right there
gobstones man i wonder if that'll be in
hogwarts legacy
like wizards chess and gobstones
little games that they play together
that'd be cool
like side quests like geez i remember
gwent from the witcher
i played so much gwent and i actually
got to where i i really
enjoyed playing gwent it was it was far
more than just like a little
side mission thing that you needed to do
if you wanted a certain trophy or
anything
no i really got to where i i actually
enjoyed playing gwent
oh an aloha mora chest okay you know
what let's go ahead and put it on
i'm gonna put it on this x button here
that way i'll have both it and scourge
ready to go
all right let's open it up there we go
that's the final wizard card we need
to upgrade our health there 57 30
circle thaddeus thurgle 1632
to 1692 what is that gerbils that he's
got there
hedgehogs famous for producing seven
squib
sons and turning them all into hedgehogs
in disgust are you serious oh my gosh
poor kids he produced
seven squibs that's kind of that's kind
of insane all right here's one that
doesn't
like what are the odds on that i don't
know how the magical world
how passing on magic works but that just
seems like
number 91 wilfred elfic
wilfred elfic 11 12 to 1199 first wizard
to be gored by an african erumpent
e-rumpent
i do not i'm gonna have to look that one
up if you guys anybody who remember
what's
who remembers what an e-rumpant is
without looking it up go ahead let me
know in the comments and then if you go
look it up you can let me know
you know you can still let me know it's
okay if you go look it up
that just kind of ruins the fun you know
like i remember reading the the
fantastic beasts the book that she put
out for charity not not the
like script or whatever for the movie
underpants no but the one that she put
out where it's like actually like
supposed to be like the school books
i do not remember on a rumpet but it's
been so long
maybe it is in there see this game was
was created long
before all that though although i do
believe they were considered canon like
the spells and stuff
they checked with her for all of that
which
is nice you know and i do wonder like
how much hogwarts legacy will
adhere to the cannon is that the deathly
hallows
dude how crazy is that that that almost
looks like the mark of the deathly
hallows is just missing the wand there
you've got the circle and then you've
got the triangle we just need the the
wand in the center
all right so i think we're totally clear
on this room though
yeah we were able to open both of those
chests
okay that's kind of creepy do you
collect famous witches of wizard cards
actually i do i'll give you card number
two cornelius agrippa
for a number 59 gregory the smarmy
card darn i was about to say i don't
think i have him
i would have totally traded with you
though man all right we already went in
there
we already went in there uh
let's see i think this is the was this
another classroom that we haven't been
in
oh there's the thing that uh the
student's missing right there
telescope all right it was worth it guys
it was totally worth making this trip oh
this is going to have a lot of very
about beans if i remember correctly
these have
well i do not remember correctly and
look at that i don't think it'll let me
i couldn't get up there to get that that
one that was on top of the desk
we'll go ahead and open these little uh
desks though and see if we can find any
more
i can't even really remember what i want
to buy at fred and george's now i think
the the big thing that i wanted was
obviously the alahomora spell
and i think they actually sell wizard
cards as well so it
certainly not going to hurt to collect
more birdy bop beans
i feel like you should get beans when
you complete missions and stuff too
that'd be nice like just like when i
when i win the quidditch match
somebody should just hand me like 50
beans on my way out you know
it's like here you go harry this is this
is to celebrate the gryffindor victory
just have 50 birdy bop beans take to the
common room
all right is there another room okay
that's transfigurat wait maybe i did i
not
check okay there's transfiguration we
just went in there did i not check this
one okay that one's locked
in that way and this is one of the
classrooms right
yeah okay that's the classroom that we
checked does this really not have any
though
and then the one that's gonna be on my
right
we checked that one too because this is
the one right when i walked out the guy
was just right in my face remember
he's just like hey dude you wanna you
wanna trade a wizard card
you wanna trade all right does this have
more beans yes it does
oh five out of that one
definitely worth it okay let's head on
up to the next floor here
uh second floor we've got charms and the
library there's the girls bathroom
[Music]
go ahead and do this one as well
okay let's go in here see if there are
any more okay that's the spot that ends
right there you can't go
up you can only slide down from the
level above
girls bathroom i don't think we can go
in there yet
it's probably a mission specific thing
okay this one i don't like this one
because
what is this lead oh yeah this is the
room that has
yeah this is this is a good room
because yeah i thought i remember these
things giving a lot of birdie about
beans
now if i opened that one already yeah it
looks like i have
let's go again and get a couple more
birdy bop beans from here
take the pumpkin pasty as well all right
i think i'm good man i think i'm good
let's go ahead and just end the day
actually we don't have to go all the way
up there
[Music]
dude violet beau regard slash
oliver wood is still standing there by
the door look at this let's see if we
could see him when
i just saw him when it zoomed in at
first oh we were destroying hufflepuff
290 to 200.
oh there he was did you see him just for
a second just for a second
250. slytherin's probably gonna be like
291 watch
let's see let's see
281 okay all right all right
we've got a nine point lead right now
i'll take that
all right into the gryffindor common
room we go let's see what
the night will bring because you know
harry is always getting up to some kind
of shenanigans
you're not going to believe this after
hours
bathroom on the second floor oh no
there we go i told you really yes about
the girl's bathroom hurry up
[Music]
second floor we were just there actually
supposed to be haunted
we were just there ron
oh it's going the wrong way
[Music]
yeah turn that in the next one is
neville's toad
uh let's see last scene near the
herbology greenhouses if found please
return
to this notice board all right so we
found three
so far neville's toad be the number four
let's go ahead and get our wizard card
for that dude we're just getting all
kinds of wizard cards tonight and it's
salazar
slytherin medieval dates unknown only
fitting that we're going after
slytherin's air right now
co-founder of hogwarts gave his name to
one of the four hogwarts houses
all right you couldn't say a little bit
more about him than that it seems kind
of limited
should we check on fred and george let's
take a look we're up to 41
beans you know it might be worth it
[Music]
too late dude
those invis frames invincibility frames
let's see how much are the wizard cards
i want to say they're 50.
how much is his egg a stronger card
30 okay so i can buy a wizard card i'm
glad we came here
albert grunion the inventor of the dumbo
how much is that 30 30 bucks every
flavor okay so they've got one two
three four wizard cards here
or no five there's two over there feel
free to spend as long as you like it
let's see how much that i think this is
one hundred wooden world potion vial
one hundred thirty yeah every flavor
beans so we need to get one hundred for
that extra wig and well potion vial but
i'm gonna go ahead and buy one of these
wizard cards today
oh we're in here how much is that
thirty birthday box every flavor beans
i'm gonna go with whichever name
sounds the coolest the limited edition
oh limited edition
what does that cost 30 30
limited edition birdie bot i'd like to
buy that we gotta go with the limited
edition
especially since it doesn't cost anymore
his real genius was in the invention of
the unreleased dog spit flavored bean
oh say what
all right let's take a look at the card
69 bertie bott
bertie bought number 69 1935 to present
inventor of bertie bought every flavor
beans
all right very nice take a look around
potter so
take a look around now we're good we've
got to go
back now and head to the girls bathroom
my friends
hold on i think it's right here the
little secret way
to get back got to get lumos up and
going
so we can sneak through the hidden
passage
then it takes us back this way
[Music]
and then we're back in here with the
prefect but he doesn't even know we're
here
doesn't even know you guys all right so
now we need to go
to what was the second floor i believe
second floor for the girls bathroom
all right gotta make our way back
downstairs
collect a few birdie about beans as we
go since you know
there's going to be all kinds of ghosts
there's going to be stuff coming after
us trying to prevent us from
collecting these birdy bop beans that's
just how it works in this game
okay defense against the dark arts wait
for the stairs and down we
go i believe it was right here oh
goodness
incendio challenge chambers wait this is
not where it was it was the first floor
wasn't it
no stay away
what's the third floor i'm second
guessing it now
hold on transfiguration
guys i was not kidding if you've watched
the other
uh episodes in this series or my other
let's plays you know
that i am terrible with directions i am
seriously terrible with directions
how is it not i thought it was the
second floor
i thought i even said second floor let's
look at what the remembral says
floor two i was right okay that actually
makes me feel
not as bad that i i was actually correct
i just didn't look at the right okay
there it is
get all these silly enchanted books away
from me
you got this is when you guys are going
to be like actually retro you walked by
it you looked
right at it you even read the words and
kept going
it honestly wouldn't surprise me
hermione
would not surprise me in the least if i
did that oh there's myrtle
no sorry myrtle i just wanted to show
him how
nice it is in here are we about to take
apologies right now
without ron
so what's his plan of yours hermione we
need to find out who the heir of
slytherin is so we can discover who
wants all the students with non-magical
parents out of hogwarts well
it's not me i hope do you think it could
be draco
well if it is how do we prove it she's
only got one cup
get malfoy to answer a few questions
without him realizing it's us
that's what i was thinking which is why
i've been making apologies ah
so she's already been making a potion it
transforms you into somebody else
one of us could change into a slytherin
and malfoy would probably tell us
anything we wanted to know i managed to
sneak a bit of goyal's hair during
transfiguration class
and mix it into this oh one sit harry
and you'll look just like royal
oh great oh here he goes
so he's gotta go alone they don't have
him go with them in this
hey are you okay or they don't have ron
rather
on fire good fine try and find malfoy
he's usually lurking about the dungeons
this time of night
that dude i forgot about this this is
great oh can you talk to myrtle
a boy get away get
away this is crazy
dude i totally forgot about this
i mean obviously they're gonna have this
moment in the game at least part of it
i suppose i should really be meeting up
with malfoy in the dungeons
[Music]
all right get away from me enchanted
books we must head down into the
dungeons
now to get to the dungeons i believe we
go
wait i remember hold on hold on i think
i got it guys
all right i'm pretty sure they are over
this way
yeah there we go i'm gonna get so lost
in hogwarts legacy
i'm gonna get so lost i can't wait
though man
i can't wait
all right this way wait for the bloody
baron to pass
and into the dungeons we go
all right do i need to be on the lookout
for
what if you were actually on a timer
that'd be awesome
like as your polyjuice is about to run
out okay am i supposed to sneak around
here did they get are they gonna have
oh i just can't the camera in this game
you guys
did you know that draco's looking for
you
okay sure okay
all right where is he my father says
that only pure bloods like us should be
at hogwarts so i don't have to
hide oh hey let's search this treasure
while we're here
wizard card let's go i don't know why
you guys have just been walking around
not
taking this wizard card in here number
43 cyprian yaldor
okay we got two of him now cyprian
yaddle that was the guy oh yeah the only
quidditch referee ever to be killed
during a match the originator of the
curse was never caught
but believed to have been a member of
the crowd 1312
to 1357. all right we need to make sure
there's not
anything else in here there we go
another one
another wizard card it's awesome
[Applause]
number 86 darkest well beloved
dorcas well beloved now here we go you
guys
anybody watching this who's looking
forward to hogwarts legacy
late 1800s we know is the time frame so
dorcas well beloved here lived from 1812
to 1904 the founder of the society for
distressed
witches that's interesting that
like that doesn't ring a bell to me
right away like i don't remember that
coming up in the canon
but i'm gonna have to do some research
on that after this after recording this
because that could very well be a plot
line that we see
in parts of hogwarts legacy founder of
the society for distressed witches
so interesting dorcas well beloved the
name of that one right there
all right i'm gonna keep looking did you
know that draco's looking for you
yeah i don't care about draco right now
you guys
i'm about to blast you with a flapindo
spell here
um instead what i'm looking for is more
wizard cards because apparently
the slytherin dungeons are where they
keep all these wizard cards
lying around just hiding in treasure
chests
if that potter can speak to snakes
enemies of the air beware
you'll be next
okay is this it there's nothing more to
the dungeons
okay it's not good it's not gonna let us
see anything else all right what up
draco
you know goyle i'm surprised the daily
prophet hasn't reported what's going on
here
i suppose dumbledore's trying to hash it
all up
he'll be sacked if it doesn't stop soon
it's amazing how you can hear the movie
lines
instantly he was the worst thing that
ever happened to hogwarts
he loves that non-magical lot a decent
headmaster would
never have let that jumped up granger
mud blood in
jumped up the saint potter the
mudblood's friend
he's another one with no proper wizard
feeling
and people think he's the slytherin heir
i wish i knew who it is i could help
them
oh you must have some idea
who's behind it all you know i have a
coil
how many times do i have to tell you but
i know
one thing last time the chamber of
secrets was opened
a mudblood girl died so i bet it's only
a matter of time before one of them's
killed this time
i hope it's granger man anyway
uh is it really possible for like a 12
year old to have
that much hate in their heart i hope not
i really hope not yes that's
[Music]
before your fat belly explodes
oh now he's gonna transform back out of
here and fast
oh and he loses his robes too you gotta
be kidding me man
oh no this is bad
like i can't see anything because of
this terrible camera
okay okay we're good
oh good thing we got all of the uh
goodness
good thing we got all those chests
beforehand
all right back to money oh goodness
gracious run
whoo he's about to walk right into him
all right so back to moaning minerals
bathroom
trust me i remember where it is this
time
i remember where it is guys second floor
take a left right here we go well
it isn't him mouth was not the heir of
slytherin
oh he must be oh who
else could it be i don't know but it's
got to be someone who was here at
hogwarts 50 years ago
when the chamber was last opened
well done harry you did a great job see
you in the morning
bye harry
oh and they just leave him in here
myrtle anything to say to me
just the same thing all right anything
in here that we missed
hey i know how to get down there
[Music]
dude you know everybody's gonna be
looking for the chamber of secrets when
uh hogwarts legacy comes out
everybody's gonna be trying to get into
the chamber that would be a pretty cool
easter egg though
if you think about it oh man guys i
think that's gonna do it for today's
episode so
gryffindor vs hufflepuff we completed
the quidditch match and then
harry took polyjuice potion to determine
that
draco malfoy is not the heir of
slytherin so we will pick back up
right here next time as always thank you
all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon